Here were the two original inequalities and these were the solutions, x less
than negative 3 or x less than or equal to negative 4. Let's compare the two
number lines. It's harder to see the number lines compared horizontally, so
let's stack them on top of each other. When looking at the number lines, we
values of x that satisfy this inequality or this inequality. So, we want all of
these values. Any value within this region or any value within this region
satisfies one of the conditions. Notice that the top number line is contained
entirely within the second one. That means, we only need the solutions that are
less than negative 3. Any value that's less than negative 3 will work in this
first inequality and any value less than negative 4 will work in this
inequality. That's why we want this region. We want these values or these
values, so we show all these values on one number line. This is our solution
set. Any value of x for negative infinity up to negative 3 but not including
negative 3 will work. x needs to be less than negative 3. In interval notation,
we list it like this. This is a really tough problem. So, if you got the one
right, great work.